what's your name I'm Aaron and where you
from Detroit Michigan cool and do you
have an example of something you're
scared to share with people not anymore
but in the past I used to be scared to
share my sexuality when did you get over
that you actually it takes a long time
to get over it
amongst close friends I'd say I was
about 19 but with my family it wasn't
till I was about 22 23 and then with
everybody not caring anymore it wasn't
until I was 32
I'm 40 now so it shows you I've only
been free for a short while can ask the
fault question sure what was what do you
think you're scared of for me it had a
lot to do with being prejudged or the
being presumed to be a certain way I
wanted people to know me first before
they interpreted my sexuality so I was
scared of rejection I think if you look
at the whole rejection
I think a big one would be fake it's
like I am a Christian and that's not
something I'm ashamed of but I know
going into it with a stranger sometimes
something as simple as faith can turn
people off like that and so I would like
to like talk to them first
and have an opportunity because
sometimes when you if they find that out
right away they could shut down and so
with a stranger that would be something
that's a little I'm a little scared too
just because of how the world operates
today maybe things that like happened in
the past inside your household are like
like deep and maybe don't want to share
with other people but sometimes those
getting those out really just lets you
just be yourself more instead of like a
closed show I'm scared to share that I
don't like being alone so I find
[Music]
different people to crazy
I find different people to find these
little things that I like and even then
I don't even want to settle down so I
just keep hopping from person to person
why do you think you're scared to share
that with people because people and this
day and age think that it's bad to be
open and to everyone wants a
relationship everybody wants to get
married everybody wants to have kids and
when you're a single person and you
don't really want to settle down you
want to be openness kind of like a
what's the word I'm trying to use taboo
my ethnicity oldest my ethnicity I
really like that
because I want it not to matter but it
matters yeah I'm scared to share with
people that I have a fear of drowning
being bipolar that I stutter sometimes
I'm afraid of the dark
I am terribly afraid of heights I am a
very grounded person but I feel alone
my own insecurities I'm afraid to show
my emotions
[Music]
probably my anxiety my anxiety level
that I have depression and anxiety
because a lot of people are judgmental
and I honestly I don't want sympathy for
it I don't want people to look at me
differently so and I don't to use it as
a crutch so I kind of just keep it to
myself for the most part I guess you
could say like I'm pretty like reclusive
and like social anxiety and if you like
don't really know me I'm like really
quiet so that's something like people
don't really know about me and that's
like something I don't really share with
people but I try my best to like fit
into normal society like acting normal
but it's something that I deal with like
every day that's the whole question sure
why do you think that you might be
scared to share that with people because
I think people will think of me
differently and like you know just it's
like judgment and then that just leads
to negative thoughts and such
that I'm very shy I don't like to let
people know how shy I am
oh because they'll take advantage of you
if they find out you're not aggressive
self-promoting probably just that I'm
afraid my car's gonna break down all the
time because you know it's all about
perception um it's about you know it's
it's how you show yourself to the world
so people think differently about you if
you like
tell them steps wrong versus if you act
like everything is okay I guess my
biggest thing is that we're always
taught to pretend that everything is
always okay and that we're really
successful and that we're doing a lot
better than we are
so I guess my big fear is to actually
tell people that half the time I'm
really freaked out I have no idea what
I'm doing and I'm definitely afraid that
I'll fail it's something I'm fighting
with right now actually it's just to
even admit that I have fears because
everyone does and sometimes you want to
tell yourself you don't but you know
there's some deep stuff with everybody
that there's some fear somewhere you
know growing up being a poor kid you
know I didn't grow up with really
anything I was homeless with my mom
growing up and I've done a lot to be
successful I was the first person to
graduate college in my family but I
still have that fear of you know
being that way that I had to grow up you
know what I mean being homeless or being
a less fortunate kid growing up
especially in San Diego where a lot of
kids have a lot of things and you can
really notice the difference of not
having things that's my biggest fear
what am I too scared to share with you I
mean we just came from a music festival
so and it was at a nudist resort so
there is a lot of you know like lots of
uninhibited energy so for now this is
like freshly off of that it's kind of
funny to think of what am I too scared
to share with people you know like you
know old open new just walking around
like it's no big deal and and then it
sets the whole energy for the whole best
to be like just no inhibitions so um I
don't know what am I too free to show
people I need to sing more and I'm a
vocalist
and I'm a violin player and people tell
me to sing all the time sometimes I'm
just scared to do it being an artist I
never wanted to play solo violin or solo
viola growing up I always want to be in
a group in anarchist dress so that's
definitely something I do now today that
I used to be too scared to share with
people but I've gotten over I'm a
performer now so that's all I do
Wow
I'm not scared about much or anything
really got another question no I mean
that's awesome that you're not scared
now how about I do feel like at this
point in your life in my skin has there
been the point in your life where you
might have been what that I used to be
scared of
oh man I'm trying to remember oh gosh
maybe should let me think about it yeah
well let's see the reason why I'm not
afraid of anything
it's because I give myself a lot of
freedom and I'm I'm not attached to the
outcome of things does that make sense
what's up guys my name is Brian and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean a lot thank you